[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
abend mehr als
160.000 neuinfektionen und die inzidenz
bei über 900 das sind die zahlen an die
man sich jetzt gewöhnt gegen diese welle
würde eine impfpflicht auch nicht mehr
helfen das käme dafür zu spät die
befürworter habe vielmehr den nächsten
herbst im blick wenn es dann wieder los
geht mit neuen wellen und neuen
varianten wie das dann überhaupt in
deutschland praktisch umgesetzt werden
könnte ist eine der fragen die ich karl
lauterbach vor hingestellt habe auch
erst mal berichtet wenn die herrscher
über die erste impfpflicht debatte heute
im bundestag
olaf scholz steuert sein platz auf der
regierungsbank an er wird sich hier
heute nicht positionieren obwohl er als
abgeordneter scholz ja für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ist er hat auch
keinen antrag mitgebracht er will als
bundeskanzler zu hören quasi neutral
fast vier stunden debatte bedenken wir
dabei dass die menschen in dieser
angespannten zeit von uns vor allem
orientierung erwarten orientierung sucht
auch das parlament hier sitzen
zustimmung und zweifel nur wenige meter
neben grundsätzlicher ablehnung wobei
das jahr zu einer impfpflicht ob ab 18
jahren oder später die heute überwiegt
kein experte kann uns heute sagen dass
die pandemie mit omikron weitgehend
überstanden sein wird keiner gibt uns
die sicherheit nicht von weiteren
virusvarianten überrascht zu werden
diese ungewissheit darf aber eben nicht
zu tatenlosigkeit führen die gefahr
durch profit 19 schwer zu erkranken
dauerhafte gesundheitsschäden zu
erleiden oder sogar zu sterben wird
massiv unterschätzt
stattdessen fürchten sich noch viel zu
viele vor den sehr sicheren und
inzwischen milliardenfach erprobten
impfstoffen die einen schweren verlauf
mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit verhindern
können und es fällt mir natürlich auch
nicht leicht da zu sagen das ist der
beste weg durch diese krise und aus
dieser
aber es ist auf jeden fall so dass wir
hier versuchen die gesellschaftlichen
nebenwirkungen die dieses medikament
impfpflicht auch haben kann mitzudenken
und die zu minimieren wolfgang kubicki
ist gegen eine impfpflicht er hat
verfassungsrechtliche bedenken andere
glauben noch an alternativen und wieder
andere haben vor allem weniger argumente
als wütende worte
die absicht eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gegen das corona virus einzuführen ist
ein anschlag auf die freiheit und
menschenwürde und auf grundrecht auf die
körperliche unversehrtheit von diensten
wichtig ist müssen wir einen anderen weg
gehen aufklärung aufklärung aufklärung
wenn die hälfte gilt wäre bis zum herbst
werden wir ein großes problem los das
bedeutete pro tag 25.000 menschen und
das sollen uns nicht durch aufklärung
gelingt das kann ich überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen einen massiven
grundrechtseingriff mit einer möglichen
rot ab dem herbst zu begründen die wir
noch nicht kennen und einen impfstoff
die wir noch nicht haben sozusagen eine
impfpflicht auf vorrat halte ich auch
aus rechtlicher sicht für licht täter
bei der union wird nur klar dass sie
ohne antrag und gegen olaf scholz ist
die fraktionsspitze hat das taktisch so
vorgegeben karl lauterbach der
symbolisch im plenum platz genommen hat
wittert irgendwann wütend der union
würde es nur um parteipolitik gehen in
eine der zentralen fragen in der größten
krise der nachkriegszeit
die bundesregierung sich weigert eine
eigene position zu beziehen dann ist die
wertung flucht aus der verantwortung
noch das freundlichste was mir dazu
einfällt mandate ob olaf scholz die
debatte gut für sich sortiert hat es ist
vieles gesagt wurden aber noch ist offen
welchen weg dieses parlament ganz
konkret gehen wird
und der bundesgesundheitsminister ist
sonst aus berlin zugeschaltet guten
abend herr lauterbach
grundversorger sie sind ja heute
bundestag explizit nicht als
gesundheitsminister aufgetreten ist das
nicht irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig
wenn der mann der mutmaßlichen der
bundesregierung will ich auch im
parlament die meisten ahnung von corona
hat nicht mal einen eigenen vorschlag
macht naja hier ging es ja um eine
wichtige ethische debatte um die
impfpflicht und da kann nicht nur als
abgeordneter sprechen so eine
gewissensentscheidung und von daher habe
ich mich auch ganz gezielt ins plenum
heute gesetzt doch nicht auf die
regierungsbank hier war ich ein
abgeordneter von vielen debatte das
erinnert an begriffe die man verwendet
hat zum beispiel über sterbehilfe wo es
auch ganz stark um religiöse fragen geht
ist das für und wider impfen nicht eher
eine wissenschaftliche evidenz frage
oder eine moral frage das ist hier eine
moral frage war ich muss ja quasi die
körperliche unversehrtheit
muss ich angreifen um einen anderen
menschen oder vielleicht den menschen
selbst zu schützen und somit geht es
schon also um grundrechte hier werden
grundrechte gegeneinander abgewogen und
dann kommt typischerweise wenn es also
diese dimension hat die gesamte
bevölkerung dann kommt schon die
ethische frage hoch aber letztendlich
sind ja keine ethischen gründen das die
regierung kann eigenen vorschlag
vorlegen dass sie keine eigene mehrheit
karte paaren das wird immer wieder
vorgetragen also was soll denn das ganze
nur taktik wäre aus rücksicht auf die
fdp würde die ampel hier in eine
ethische debatte also vortäuschen das
ist aber nicht richtig sondern es geht
tatsächlich um
grundrechtseingriffe es geht um
eingriffe die eine solche tiefe haben
das ja schon bevor wir das überhaupt
also beschließen auf der straße für das
für und wieder demonstriert wird und das
geht schon sehr tief in die gesellschaft
in all das könnte spalten wenn wir nicht
gemeinsam agieren also man weiß ja auch
nicht wie das dann am ende im bundestag
ausgehen würde und mal angenommen es
käme eine impfpflicht wo wir sie ja
vorzügen und wollen wie würde das dann
in deutschland praktisch umgesetzt und
im register wie die in österreich
italiener haben wir ja nicht in der tat
ich bin selbst nicht davon überzeugt
dass wir einen regisseur hier brauchen
und sicherlich hätten wir es nicht in
der zeit die uns zur verfügung steht wir
müssen ja die welle im herbst hier im
auge behalten wir wollen ja die welle im
herbst also verhindert die schwerere
welle was könnte erneut mikro und sagen
das könnte eine data werde es sein das
könnte auch eine kombination sein was
noch viel gefährlicher wäre
und wenn ich das erreichen will dann
mussten wir jetzt schnell handeln da
kann kein freak ist also wie soll das
praktisch gehen aber einwohnermeldeämter
oder steuerbehörden oder würde man das
dann machen es gibt unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten also wie man das machen
könnte wichtig ist dass folgende das ja
nur eine kleine gruppe die hier geimpft
werden muss und diese leute die müssen
tatsächlich dann auch mit bußgeldern
rechnen müssen weil wir kriegen das
nicht durch indem wir appellieren wenn
wir weiter mit appellen arbeiten und
dann sind wir nicht schnell genug die
impfpflicht muss in den nächsten wochen
beschlossen werden so dass sie im herbst
wirklich die wirkung hält aber noch mal
die frage was ein für ein technisches
tool würde man das machen es gibt so
viele möglichkeiten also eine
möglichkeit wäre zum beispiel also dass
der im nachweis erbracht werden muss an
den arbeitsplatz zum beispiel oder
beispielsweise bei der nutzung
bestimmter verkehrsmittel es wäre
möglich dass also nimmt nachweis
erbracht werden muss also bei
arztbesuchen in kliniken usw also man
könnte sich hier vieles denken es könnte
auch einfach schlicht sporadisch
kontrolliert werden wie in österreich
ich glaube dass die kontrolle frage
überbewertet ist wenn das endlich da ist
und es gibt empfindliche strafen dann
würden die maßen sich auch impfen lassen
und hatten sich also für sehr viel ärger
bei den ministerpräsidenten der länder
gesorgt mit dieser genesenen status
geschichte wo das rk ii dann plötzlich
von sechs monaten auf drei monate
runterging und hat die eu gerade
beschlossen die eu kommission das ist in
europa einheitlich nach möglichkeit
sechs monate sein sollen wie so will
deutschland da jetzt unbedingt diesen
sonderweg gehen es gibt doch wirklich
nur auf allen seiten ärger damit es
stimmt das ist ärgerlich aber der ärger
lohnt sich hier war die drei monate sind
wissenschaftlich richtig dass es leider
so da ist die eu kommission schlecht
beraten ein bisschen ja sie war nicht
schlecht beraten wir haben uns ja auf
der eu ebene auch für die drei monate
eingesetzt also das was wir jetzt in
deutschland durchsetzen konnten haben
wir auch versucht europa außer
durchzusetzen und die verordnung wird ja
immer wieder angepasst das heißt wir
werden in kürze erneut versuchen die
drei monate auf europäischer ebene
umzusetzen aber man muss ja hier also
mal loslösen also wäre sich durch und zu
warten
ein von der frage ist es richtig und es
ist wissenschaftlich einfach richtig
nach drei monaten kann sich derjenige
der mit der data variante schon
infiziert war erneut mit der omicron
variante infizieren somit sind die drei
monate wissenschaftlich richtig das
robert-koch-institut hat daher
konsequent hier empfohlen ich stehe
daher auch für diesen beschluss aber das
macht nicht populärer wie wenig die
bevölkerung schützen will muss nicht
jeder beschluss populär sein stichwort
bevölkerung schützen was im moment die
bevölkerung erlebt jedenfalls alle die
kinder haben ist das umgekommen durch
die schulen rausch also auch kinder die
jetzt zwei jahre wirklich gut
durchgehalten haben die liegen jetzt
auch positiv zu hause im bett oder auch
nicht je nachdem dieses verkraften oder
die ganzen halbe klassen sind weg wenn
eine natürliche infektion so wenig
bringt dann messen lassen wir jetzt
quasi die ganze jugend sich infizierung
und das durch rauschen und dann haben
die noch nicht mal was davon in der tat
also diese durch solche die ich falsch
finde bei kindern wie bei wachsen und
auch bei kindern navi risiken die bringt
es keine immunisierung das ist leider so
also ich habe ich habe gelesen dass es
zum beispiel auch durch solche partys
gibt dafür gar nicht nur warnen
derjenige der glaubt dass er mit der
nikon infektion nachdem er sich schon
gefährdet hat danach wenigstens sicher
wer vor weiteren ansteckungen ja also
hat der hat mit zitronen gehandelt und
das ist definitiv falsch teil müssen wir
kinder schützen und ich warne davor die
infektionen als eine natürliche
immunisierung zu sehen
das hat ja auch nicht mal mehr garantien
es gibt keine pcs mehr für die kinder
die logitech schlagen zum teil nicht an
da haben die schon symptome es gibt
keine quarantäne regeln mehr in berlin
wird man nicht mal der schweiz nachbar
in der schule dann mit nach hause
geschickt also wir haben doch nur
durchseuchung an den schulen ja nicht
überall also schon von bundesland zu
bundesland es gibt also auch noch
bundesländer wo die leute tests gemacht
werden in sehr vielen schulen werden
noch die anti gen test gemacht wenn man
die regelmäßig macht dann ist das sehr
wertvoll ich rate auch immer zu guten
masken die studien zeigen dass die
kinder auch mit masken sehr gut lernen
können dass die also lernfähigkeit da
nicht beeinträchtigt wird aber es ist
tatsächlich so wir haben eine sehr
ansteckende variante und die sichere
alternative wäre einfach von den
präsenzunterricht zu stoppen aber das
hat wiederum ganz andere konsequenzen
somit sind wir in einer situation wo es
schwer ist werden wir die fallzahlen
insgesamt runter bekämen würde sich das
auch für die kinder auszahlen wenn die
lämmer
minister danke für das gespräch ich
danke ihnen
die russen stehen mit 100000 mann an der
grenze zur ukraine
deutschland will helfen und schickt 5000
militärische schutzhelme nach kiew als
signal wir stehen an eurer seite die
ministerin lambrecht im
verteidigungsausschuss sagte die geste
kommt bei der ukrainischen regierung
allerdings nicht so gut an nicht mal ein
trostpflaster sei das richtete ihr
botschafter in berlin aus auch bei den
nato verbündeten sorgt deutschland
zunehmend für irritation immerhin saß
berlin heute erstmals wieder im so
genannten normandie format mit am tisch
das diesmal in paris stattfand andreas
kühn as berichtet
die pariser polizei steht am mittag der
hoffnung im weg der hoffnung den ersten
offiziellen handschlag zu sehen zwischen
russland und der ukraine seit drei
jahren so abgeschirmt so abgesichert
waren die kontrahenten dem élysée palast
vor dass die kameras heute nur einen
erwischen russlands vize
ministerpräsident korsakow der vertreter
moskaus dem vertreter kiews die hand
gegeben hat wird nicht bekannt vor allem
russland tut sich schwer mit dem
normandie format rüdiger von fritsch war
fünf jahre lang botschafter in moskau
und hat es erlebt
die prozess und das wenn man die format
ist für russland nicht immer angenehm
auch für die ukraine
weil jeweils jeder ein stück bei die
karten auf den tisch legen muss und
erklären warum diese oder jene
bestimmung nicht erfüllt seit es 2014 in
der normandie kanzlerin merkel und
präsident gelungen ist russland und die
ukraine an einen tisch zu bekommen ist
das normandie format das einzige forum
geblieben in dem die gag närrischen
präsidenten aufeinandertreffen moderiert
von frankreich und deutschland nach
paris haben die chefs heute ihre
wichtigsten ratgeber geschickt aus
deutschland jens plötner den außen- und
sicherheitspolitischen berater von
kanzler scholz blödtner war vor dem
treffen in moskau und kiew und was er
gehört hat klingt nicht gut
wenn wir das keine konstruktive art und
der west in seinem aggressiven kurs
fortsetzt wird moskau die notwendigen
vergeltungsmaßnahmen ergreifen
dass unser ostmitteleuropäischen sich
militärisch entblößen russland droht
schweden und finnland sollten sie
nato-operation gegen russland verlangt
dass die usa ihre nuklearen schutzschirm
überhaupt zurück sind das sind die
drohungen im raum stehen und hierauf
gilt es entschlossen zu reagieren
deutschland hat lange gezögert der
ukraine auch praktisch zu helfen
waffenlieferungen lehnt die
bundesregierung ab die
verteidigungsministerin erfüllt aber den
wunsch schutzhelme zur verfügung zu
stellen das sofort geprüft und wir
werden 5000 helme an die ukraine liefern
auch als ganz deutliches signal wir
stehen an eurer seite ich finde es
richtig dass die bundesregierung
grundsätzlich ihre strikte haltung jetzt
etwas lockert anderer systemen starke
zeichen aus meiner sicht anders aus am
abend verlässt der botschafter der usa
das russische außenministerium er hat
die mit den verbündeten abgestimmte
antwort abgegeben auf moskaus
forderungen der us aussenminister fasst
zusammen rüstungskontroll gespräche ja
rückzug der nato aus osteuropa nein
wir haben klargestellt dass wir kein
grundsätze verteidigen werden wie die
souveränität der ukraine und das recht
von staaten eigene bündnisse zu wählen
die pariser polizei hat heute mittag die
sicht auf die hoffnung versperrt obwohl
stand heute abend noch immer nicht klar
ist ob es hoffnung gibt
frage an eine gellinek amerikaner nato
haben also ihre botschaften übergeben
und das ist im grunde ein njet richtung
moskau oder
ja die nato hat auf fünf seiten
dargelegt was eigentlich auch in moskau
niemanden mehr überrascht haben dürfte
nämlich dass die russischen
hauptanliegen danach dass es einen stopp
der nato osterweiterung geben soll dass
es eine zusicherung geben soll dass die
ukraine niemals nato-mitglied wird und
das nato truppen nicht mehr in
osteuropäischen ländern stationiert
werden sollten dass diese forderung und
für die nato absolut unerfüllbar sind
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg hat
heute abend noch einmal bekräftigt dass
jedes land das recht habe seine
bündnisse selbst zu wählen und das gelte
selbstverständlich auch für die ukraine
dieser brief also dieser antwortbrief
der nato ist eine ziemliche abfuhr für
russlands hauptanliegen aber er ist
verbunden mit einem angebot einem
angebot doch über rüstung zu sprechen
über mittel und kurzstreckenraketen und
auch darüber sich wieder gegenseitig zu
informieren über übungen und
truppenbewegungen moskau wird diesen
brief jetzt studieren und man muss kein
prophet sein um anzunehmen dass es
leider die mir putin nicht reichen wird
in einer ersten reaktion heute abend aus
moskau hieß es die antwort der nato
bedeutet null fortschritt
und will sich jetzt aber noch mal in
diesem normandie format offenbar auch
treffen dass deutschland sich in dieser
ganzen sache eher zurück nimmt das kommt
ja vor allem in osteuropa wirklich
schlecht an
ja es gab heute kritik vom polnischen
vize außenminister der den die blockade
des weiterverkaufs von ehemals deutschen
geschützen an estland durch deutschland
kritisiert hat er hat gesagt das sei
symbolpolitik die in dieser speziellen
lage völlig unangebracht sei auch andere
länder unter anderem großbritannien
haben gelästert über die lieferung von
5.000 helmen nach kiew und sogar der
amerikanische außenminister anthony
blinken wurde heute abend in der
pressekonferenz gefragt ob denn
deutschland noch ein zuverlässiger
bündnispartner sei er enthielt sich
jeder kritik und sagte er glaube fest an
die solidarität deutschlands und jedes
land habe eben unterschiedliche
genehmigungsverfahren und fähigkeiten ja
diplomat dankeschön an nach brüssel
jetzt macht hans wolff weiter mit den
nachrichten da gibt's auch erst noch mal
ums krone thema das
bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe
hat einen fdp antrag zur zweig plus
regelung abgewiesen zwei politiker der
partei wollten trotz zweige plus
regelung auch ohne impfnachweis zugang
zum bundestag bekommen der antrag auf
erlass einer einstweiligen anordnung sei
unzulässig so das gericht am donnerstag
wollten die beiden politiker zum tag des
gedenkens an die opfer des
nationalsozialismus auf der
besuchertribüne an der gedenkstunde
teilnehmen
die spd-politikerin jasmin fach chemie
soll vorsitzende des deutschen
gewerkschaftsbundes werden das teilte
der dgb bundesvorstand in berlin mit
rahimi wäre damit die erste frau an der
spitze des gewerkschaftsbundes der
bisherige vorsitzende rainer hoffmann
scheidet aus altersgründen aus dem amt
aus
der britische premierminister boris
johnson der wegen vorwürfen über partys
am regierungssitz während des krolock
downs unter druck steht will die
amtsgeschäfte normal weiterführen die
heute vor abgeordneten im unterhaus in
london erklärte
die opposition bekräftigte ihre
rücktrittsforderung und verlangte die
vollständige veröffentlichung eines
untersuchungsberichts zu dem party
vorwürfen der voraussichtlich frühestens
morgen vorliegen soll
nach einwöchigen gefechten ist der
angriff der terror miliz islamischer
staat auf ein gefängnis im nordosten von
syrien niedergeschlagen worden die
terror miliz hatte die haftanstalt in
der stadt al fakka gestürmt um
inhaftierte anhänger zurück bei kämpfen
mit kurdisch geführten truppen waren
laut angaben der syrischen
beobachtungsstelle für menschenrechte
181 menschen getötet worden einigen
insassen gelang die flucht es war der
größte angriff des seit drei jahren
in diesen tagen wurde ja an die nicht zu
fassende unmenschlichkeit der
wannseekonferenz erinnert und morgen ist
gedenktag für die opfer des
nationalsozialismus
bundespräsident steinmeier besuchte am
vortag das frühere konzentrationslager
sachsenhausen nördlich von berlin allein
dort waren mehr als 200.000 menschen
inhaftiert
steinmeier mahnte die erinnerung an die
ns-verbrechen wachzuhalten
tatsächlich scheinen erschreckend viele
menschen in deutschland wenig ahnung vom
holocaust zu haben laut einer jetzt
veröffentlichten neuen antisemitismus
studio können 60 prozent noch nicht mal
genau sagen dass sechs millionen juden
ermordet wurden das kann man eigentlich
kaum fassen es sind aber nicht die
einzigen erschütternden erkenntnisse die
diese studie hervor bringt nicola
albrecht berichtet war das gleich nach
der befreiung von auschwitz oder warum
hast du so kurze haare für rosa jelinek
23 jahre alt deutsch und jüdisch sind
solche antisemitischen übergriffen nicht
schockierend sie sind alltag alltag in
deutschland wo derzeit fast jeder dritte
zwischen 18 und 29
antisemitisch denkt zum beispiel glaubt
juden haben zu viel macht und einfluss
nur ein ergebnis der aktuellen
antisemitismus studie des jüdischen
weltkongress in new york
das ausmaß des antisemitismus ist
ausgerechnet in der bundesrepublik so
hoch wie nie zuvor und fakt ist das ist
gefährlich denn es betrifft die nächste
generation
um darüber zu diskutieren haben wir uns
in potsdam mit rosa jelinek und drei
weiteren jüdischen und nichtjüdischen
studierenden verabredet auch sie haben
den eindruck dass sich etwas verändert
hat also sich etwas zutrauen was ich vor
zehn jahren vielleicht noch nicht so
getraut wurde und das viel viel mehr
sagt bahr ist das und drumherum im
umfeld die leute nichts dagegen sagen
ich das eben zum soziales korrektiv
nicht das was ihnen und in der studie
besonders auffällt die korona pandemie
ein brandbeschleuniger und viele laufen
mit wie diese antisemitismus der glaube
ich bei vielen geschlafen hat dann so
ausbrechen konnte die leute das gefühl
haben okay jetzt können wir es ja sagen
also wenn das schon die leute mit dem
gelben stern und ungeimpft unterwegs
sind dann kann ich das jetzt auch
verschwörungstheorien fluten zu dem die
sozialen netzwerke und jeder dritte
befragte stimmt zu sid juden als urheber
und profiteure der pandemie auch der
mythos der jüdischen weltverschwörung
hat wieder konjunktur
frankfurt regiert
da kommt die familie rothschild
und noch etwas zeigt die studie dass
konkrete wissen über den holocaust nimmt
ab für maxfeld hacke und rosa jelinek
nicht nur eine frage der allgemeinen
bildung sondern des umgangs mit der
eigenen familiengeschichte oft ein tabu
meinen sie wenn man weiß mein opa war
nsdap-mitglied
und dann irgendwie zu heikel zu heiß und
ich glaube dass gerade auch diese eigene
familienforschung
beispielsweise wenn das irgendwie sehr
viel weiter verbreitet wäre das wäre ja
viel mehr viel mehr dran doch was
bedeutet die bestandsaufnahme für die
zukunft der vorsitzende des jüdischen
weltkongresses ronald lauder sieht die
lage kritisch
ich glaube nicht dass wir einen weiteren
hitler sehen werden aber wir könnten
eine andere person haben die ähnlich
stark ist und hass nutzt angst nutzen um
etwas aufzubauen
maxfeld haake und rosa jelinek haben
ihre eigenen schlüsse aus ihren
erfahrungen gezogen ich bin als jude
mehr oder weniger erkennbar denn ich mit
kippa unterwegs bin und ich denke das
ist das ist gut für die öffentlichkeit
zu wissen
juden sind doch da und sie leben gerne
als juden in deutschland und noch lieber
würden sie das wenn es kein thema mehr
wäre
mit rosa jelinek die sie gerade im
bericht kennengelernt haben gibt es
später im heute-journal update noch ein
gespräch und weitere informationen und
hintergründe zu dieser antisemitismus
studie finden sie online auf zdf hat und
jetzt nochmal heinz mit dem blick auf
die deutsche wirtschaft die
bundesregierung senkt wegen der
anhaltenden corona pandemie ihre
konjunkturprognose für dieses jahr
bundeswirtschaftsminister habeck hat den
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
vorgelegt weil das heißt das wie ist die
wirtschaftslage die deutsche wirtschaft
erholt sich nur langsam von den folgen
der pandemie ist im laufe des jahres
soll die konjunkturerholung fahrt
aufnehmen und darum senkt die
bundesregierung auch ihre
wachstumsprognose nach oben korrigiert
sie hingegen die inflationsrate auf 3,3
prozent was vor allem an den hohen
energiepreisen liegt dieser erste
jahreswirtschaftsbericht war für den
neuen wirtschaftsminister habe ich
natürlich auch gelegenheit sich zu
positionieren
neu ist neben dem bruttoinlandsprodukt
das ist ja die klassische kennzahl für
wachstum soll noch andere kenngrößen die
norm werden co2 ausstoß ausgaben für
forschung der verdienstabstand zwischen
frauen und männern und ähnliches ja die
marktwirtschaft soll also nicht nur
sozial sondern auch ökologisch werden
und dann gab es am abend heute aus den
usa noch neuigkeiten zum thema zinsen ja
die neuigkeit ist so in den usa ist die
zeit der nullzinspolitik vorbei bis
anfang märz will die amerikanische
notenbank ihre wertpapierkäufe
einstellen und dann auch den leitzins
erhöhen im laufe des jahres könnte die
fed dann noch mehrmals nachlegen
eigentlich keine gute nachricht für die
aktienmärkte dennoch sind sie
erleichtert
denn fed-chefs paul agiert mit ruhiger
hand alles andere hätte die märkte auch
in panik versetzen können als hätten ist
die anleger schon gewusst der dax fast
euphorisch stunden bevor die fed ihre
entscheidung bekannt gemacht hat über 2
prozent im plus die große frage ist ob
die amerikanische notenbank den spagat
schafft die hohe inflation von sieben
prozent zu bekämpfen und dabei nicht
gleichzeitig die konjunktur abzuwürgen
gegen hohe energiepreise ist auch
notenbankchef paul machtlos mit
zinserhöhungen aber kann er ein zeichen
setzen dass er die hohe inflation nicht
hinnehmen wird sind die amerikaner schon
einen schritt weiter als die europäer
denn hier ist eine zinserhöhung noch in
weiter ferne valerie haller vielen dank
und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten immer ohne gewähr
38 15 19 23 41 superzahl 6 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotte punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
in den niederlanden ist die größte
meeres schleuse der welt eröffnet worden
so können jetzt auch große frachter von
der nordsee bis amsterdam fahren die
schleuse ist 500 meter lang und 18 meter
tief und wurde von könig willem
alexander per mausklick geöffnet und das
mammutprojekt stand in der kritik weil
die bauzeit sich erheblich verlängert
hatte und die kosten explodiert waren
das war von uns gleich gehts im ausland
schon mal weiter heute unter anderem mit
einer reportage aus china unser
korrespondent ulf röller zeigt wie das
land kurz vor den olympischen spielen
versucht die korona zahlen niedrig zu
halten
unser heutiger update wird nach sankt
ottilien bis morgen wieder sehen wieder
sinn
[Musik]
zugute und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das hatten wir in den letzten
wochen ja häufiger mit hohem luftdruck
über dem atlantik oder westeuropas ja
und immer wieder tiefs die uns aus dem
norden nordwesten erreichen das passiert
wieder das hier ist ein sturmtief es
bringt viel wind an den küsten dort
sturmböen im flachland durchaus auch
stürmische böen ja und dann gibt es
regen und schnee in den höheren lagen
schauen wir auf die details sind eher
nachts im norden also viele wolken mit
regen und der wind aus südwest ist
teilweise stürmisch strom böden können
auch schon dabei sein ganz im süden
merkmal wenig davon es klart auf
teilweise bildet sich nebel und die
temperaturen dazu singen bis auf minus 9
grad an den alpen die frostgrenze
verläuft etwa über der mitte
deutschlands nach norden deutlich milder
in schleswig holstein mit sechs grad mit
morgen im tagesverlauf verlagern sich
die wolken weiter richtung mitte in den
mittelgebirgen oberhalb von 800 metern
fällt schnee ganz im süden scheint die
sonne hier gibt es einige harmlose
wolken der regen kommt da noch nicht an
ganz im norden ist es windig aus
nordwest und westlichen richtungen hier
können also schon sturmböen dabei seien
temperaturen dazu höchste werte mit null
grad im vogtland 5 grad bei sonnenschein
im süden und 9 grad im nordwesten
dort wo der wind quasi auf zieht mit dem
neuen sturmtief kommt auch mildere luft
an und die nächsten tage am freitag an
den alpen schneefall kann auch länger
gehen ein bis acht grad am samstag viel
winter und vor allem in der nacht von
samstag auf sonntag ein neues sturmtief
vor allem im osten ein schöner abend